today we are seeing the effects
of long festering poisonous ideologies
at our government institutions most
notably the cia
i woke up today and i saw that the cia
had tweeted something
should uh should the nation's most
famous spy agency be tweeting in general
probably not
but it it got worse it wasn't just that
they sent out a tweet
it was what they tweeted
there was no substantive difference
between the video that the cia tweeted
this morning
and the most ridiculous diversity
and inclusion training manual from the
most crazy leftist at the wokest
corporate boardroom or university take a
listen
i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome but at 36
i refuse to internalize misguided
patriarchal ideas of what a woman
can or should be i am tired of feeling
like i'm supposed to apologize
for the space i occupy rather than
intoxicate people with my effort
my brilliance i am proud of me full stop
my parents left everything they knew and
loved to expose me to opportunities they
never had
because of them i stand here today a
proud first generation latina
and officer at cia
i'm so glad to hear that our spies
are no longer suffering from imposter
syndrome
that's that's good could you imagine if
those
spies felt like imposters
oh no that would be terrible for our
espionage apparatus
the left especially has long made an
argument to disband the cia because
they'll say oh you know the cia
it put down communist revolutions in
latin america and it propped up
strong men in certain places that
advanced our interests and we need to
none of that i find persuasive at all
the cia has done there have been plenty
of cia
agents and operatives who have done
excellent work over the years
after watching that video i am prepared
to disband the cia
let's do it let's go we've clearly this
organization has outlived its usefulness
it's always had some dodgy connections
going back at least to marcusa
but i we gotta we've it's enough that's
enough
when the central intelligence agency
which has a lot of power in this country
which exerts a lot of influence even
over electoral politics as we saw
with the interference that they
engaged in with the trump administration
names like eric charmela come to mind
the cia has a lot of power they've got a
lot of power in the shadows
and they have now adopted as they are
told us this morning
a very very radical ideology
the ideology of radical liberation
the ideology that posits that there is
such a thing as a patriarchy
which needs to be overthrown an ideology
which posits
that people ought to embrace pride the
queen of all
vices now considered the greatest virtue
according to the left
the ideology that says that we must
embrace
our racial identity as the most
important and sexual identity
as the most important aspects of who we
are
absolute poison for this country
that is now being pushed not even
secretly by our nation's
one of our nation's most secret agencies
it's being pushed right out in the open
a total takeover marcusa must be
giddy he must be dancing from the
afterlife as he looks up
at what is happening here at the cia in
the united states
all of the institutions have been
infected by this thing
hey all right am i still on youtube for
now or are they going to take more of my
videos down what i don't know
what it is even if we get the videos up
very often
you may not get a notification so make
sure you ring
the bell ring my bell ll ring my bell
subscribe like make sure that you put
yourself in the most likely position
to get notifications for our next videos
[Music]
you